und das ist ein wichtiger tag heute für
unseren für ihren geldbeutel des worts
gas umlage ja wie teuer wird dieser neue
aufschlag der auf die hohen gaspreise ja
noch mal oben drauf kommen soll die
bundesregierung legt genau das heute
fest ganz wichtiger tag
gas umlage das teuerste wort dieses
jahres ein aufschlag auf den sowieso
schon so stark gestiegenen gaspreis
warum weil die bundesregierung die
industrie schützen will die
gasimporteure ächzen unter den höheren
importpreisen auch wir alle sollen diese
kosten tragen am ende braucht es ja
einen business case gelten muss verdient
werden und deswegen werden wir per
verordnung
juniper auch den anderen unternehmen die
russische gasmengen neu beschaffen
müssen zu höheren preisen erlauben die
höheren beschaffungskosten umzulegen auf
die endverbraucher das ist ein
schwieriger schritt ein schritt der
eine hohe belastung mit sich bringt wie
teuer wird zwischen 15 und 5 cent pro
kilowattstunde
so hoch soll die gasanlage sein die
genaue höhe gibt die regierung heute
bekannt im schlimmsten fall zahlt eine
vierköpfige familie künftig 1000 euro
gas umlage pro jahr ab wann bereits ab
ende november drohen die ersten
zahlungen die gas umlage das teuerste
wort dieses jahres
wir wollen das noch mal anschaulich
machen wie teuer diese gas umlage für
uns alle für sie zu hause werden wird
und werden kann wir haben einmal mit
unseren experten drei szenarien
durchgespielt dass sozusagen noch das
günstigste szenario und auch das wird
schon richtig richtig teuer also sollte
heute das wirtschaftsministerium gegen
12 uhr wird das der fall sein sagen die
gasanlage rutscht auf 1,5 cent pro
kilowattstunde
dann ist das hier das ergebnis sie sehen
an der kamera die fährt mal groß auf
diese
357 euro das wird dann der aufschlag
sein den eine familie mit zwei kindern
im schnitt zahlen muss im günstigsten
szenario da 357 euro im monat um darauf
im jahr oben drauf dann gehen wir noch
mal ein bisschen weiter runter 214 euro
würde ein paar etwa im durchschnitt pro
jahr oben drauf zahlen mit dieser
günstigsten variante der gasanlage und
für einen singlehaushalt wenn das ja ein
bisschen weniger als 100 euro wir sind
da auf 89 euro aktuell gekommen wir
rechnen mal weiter im zweiten szenario
da haben wir mal drei cent pro
kilowattstunde angelegt und das ist dann
das ergebnis ein single würde
179 euro im schnitt oben drauf zahlen
nur die gasanlage wie gesagt paare 428
euro und dann das ist schon ein echter
schocker
714 euro im jahr obendrauf für eine
vierköpfige familie also zwei erwachsene
zwei kinder gas umlage bei 3 cent pro
kilowattstunde und dann der schlechteste
fall heute das wäre dieser hier und sie
sehen schon hier an diesen gigantischen
balken das wäre das was dann bei 5 cent
pro kilowattstunde gas umlage eine
vierköpfige familie oben drauf zahlen
müsste im jahr also das kommt auf die
gestiegenen gaspreise dann allein durch
diese umlage noch mal oben drauf
1190 euro gas umlage pro jahr tja einer
tief durchschnaufen das ist also das
szenario dass uns heute tatsächlich
erwischen könnte durch die
bundesregierung in wenigen minuten wird
dann die höhe dieser gas umlage
tatsächlich verkündet
[Musik]
bild breaking news
ja und diese informationen sollen jetzt
vorliegen also verbraucher wird insidern
zufolge zwischen 2 und 3 cent pro
kilowattstunde liegen diese höhe werde
das gemeinschaftsunternehmen der
gasnetzbetreiber tochter trading europe
am montag verkünden hieß es in
branchenkreisen
für einen vierköpfigen
durchschnittshaushalt ergibt sich somit
eine zusatzbelastung von bis zu 600 euro
im jahr ohne mehrwertsteuer in
[Musik]
information wir haben es gerade noch
durchgerechnet und jetzt also soll schon
feststehen dass diese gase umlage
zwischen zwei und drei euro pro
kilowattstunde liegen sollen also das
wird richtig richtig teuer und deswegen
sagen natürlich viele von uns viele von
ihnen zu hause längst wir können nicht
mehr genau so wie familie kelek unsere
bild reporterin marie sophie horstmann
hat diese familie besucht ich bin heute
bei englisch in melle und er und seine
familie märkten den teuer schock sie
müssen sparen und das beim lang
ersehnten sommerurlaub
2700 euro habe nennt ihn und seine
familie im monat zur verfügung hobbys ra
und die töchter melike und absolut
davon müssen sie ihre wohnung ihr auto
sprit versicherung und und unbezahlt
[Musik]
doch durch die steigenden kosten muss
die familie hier jetzt abstriche machen
ich sitze gerade zu hause aus dem
einzigen grund weil ich mir ist nicht
leisten konnte mit der familie um zu
machen denn die steigenden preise
sprenger aktuell das budget der familie
sie merken den preisanstieg in allen
lebensbereichen lebensmittel sprit
energiekosten insgesamt haben sie 2700
euro im monat zur verfügung davon gehen
schon 1200 euro für miete und
versicherungen drauf dazu kam noch
lebensmittel auto sprit haustiere
freizeit und eine laptop rate denn der
laptop wurde fürs homeschooling
gebraucht übrig bleiben 160 euro geld
zum sparen bleibt also kaum und auch
wenn die hunde kosten verursachen ist es
keine option für die familie sie
abzugeben
spaßeshalber war die überlegung da aber
hinter jedem spaß steckt auch ein
bisschen ernst wir können die hunde
nicht einfach so weg geben dass die sind
schon seit jahren bei uns und kranken
wird deswegen geben wir nicht weg obwohl
frau bücherei jetzt schon einen job
angenommen hat merken sie dass
zusätzliche gehalt kaum auf dem konto
denn es geht für die höheren kosten weg
bücher und die töchter besuchen jetzt
aktuell die familie in der türkei und
sparen dadurch unterkunftskosten für ngn
heißt es alleine zu hause bleiben ich
kann mir unseren familien urlaub nicht
leisten weil kosten von mindestens 1500
euro noch auf uns zugekommen wären und
ich spreche von mindestens 1500 euro
eine menge geld für die familie geld das
sie eigentlich sowieso nicht haben und
deshalb verbringt seinen urlaub jetzt zu
hause und versuche es so gut es geht zu
genießen wie habt ihr es jetzt gemacht
damit die anderen überhaupt in den
urlaub kann weil da war wahrscheinlich
jetzt auch gar nicht so das geld für da
oder sie haben
auch dieses geld nicht gehabt hab ich
sie nicht über gehabt und musste
notgedrungen unser dispo ein bisschen
über 10 wie lange wird es dauern bis her
dass wieder abbezahlt habt das steht in
den sternen ich weiß ja nicht ob es
jetzt besser wird ob es jetzt schlechter
wird ich habe jetzt tatsächlich den
talar nicht überall so das ist auch was
kopfschmerzen macht er kümmert sich um
die hunde geht spazieren und versucht
das zimmer der töchter günstig zu
renovieren denn diese mittlerweile aus
dem kinderzimmer heraus gewachsen doch
auch bei der renovierung hin zum
jugendzimmer geht sparen sparen sparen
wieso renoviere ich selber ich habe kein
geld um jemanden dafür einzustellen
durch youtube-videos versuche ich zu dem
hobby maler zu werden und das auch
irgendwie irgendwie in den griff zu
kriegen aber er macht die renovierung
nicht nur für seine töchter sondern auch
ein bisschen für sich denn den urlaub zu
hause alleine zu verbringen geht ihm
näher als er gedacht hätte wie sehr
vermisst ihr den papa nennen kannst du
was wir zeigen
danke ich habe euch alle lieb wenn jedes
telefonat so emotional wäre würde ich
sowieso nicht aushalten ja am handy muss
ich natürlich so gut wie möglich spielen
so dass es mir halt gut geht aber
innerlich zerfetzt mich dass ich nicht
bei den kindern sein kann ja ist es
deprimiert mich auch ein bisschen dass
ich kein urlaub insofern habe aber es
hilft ja alle nicht engin hat
zukunftsängste an den strom oder die
heizung nicht mehr bezahlen zu können in
die familie versucht schon an allen
ecken und kanten zu sparen und am ende
hat er aber vor allem einen wunsch an
die politik ich wünsche mir von der
politik und von den politikern
mitgefühl
verständnis dass sich unsere lage
versetzen vielleicht auch nur einmal den
den stift in der hand nehmen und eine
rechnung machen mit meinem gehalt mit
meinen ausgaben das ist mein einziges
und größter wunsch enki lag hat uns
heute gezeigt wie der tag vor allem
familien trifft er konnte nicht mit
seiner familie in den urlaub fahren weil
das geld einfach zu knapp ist
ja ein richtiger appell den er da
gemacht hat und wenn sie jetzt sagen mir
geht es genauso alles ist zu teuer wir
bei bild hören sie und wollen ihnen vor
allem auch eine stimme geben melden sie
sich einfach bei uns in unserem
sparfuchs schreiben sie an spar folks at
bild.de denn alles wird brutal teuer in
diesen zeiten und gerade erst ist ja
auch die nachricht reingekommen ja ganz
genau die nachricht wie hoch die
gasanlage dann tatsächlich wird die wir
alle ab november dann zahlen müssen alle
gaskunden sie soll bei bis zu drei cent
pro kilowattstunde liegen und was
bedeutet das konkret für ihren
geldbeutel kelek hat ist ja gerade
eingefordert einmal mit unserem gehalt
runter rechnen mit ihrem gehalt runter
rechnen und genau das haben wir gemacht
zeigen wir noch mal ganz schnell also
wenn die kreisumlage tatsächlich drei
cent pro kilowattstunde beträgt dann
kommen da kosten von 180 euro etwa für
einen single obendrauf von
428 euro für einen durchschnitts pärchen
in deutschland das mit gas heizt und ja
bis zu 700 euro und mehr für eine
vierköpfige familie also dass die
bundesregierung gerade bekanntgegeben
die gas umlage die soll so heißt es von
insidern bei bis zu drei cent pro
kilowattstunde liegen und das kommt dann
obendrauf noch mal auf den sowieso schon
hohen gaspreis für
[Musik]